♫ We're unstoppable.
- Everyday at 3:00 p.m. we're
posting on this channel.
- On the Gary Vaynerchuk channel.
- Yeah.
- YouTube, we're a lot of fun right now,
DailyVee, I'm so obsessed
with only posting DailyVee
on the GaryVee YouTube channel
that I'm creating a secondary
channel /GaryVaynerchuk
for my business meetings, my keynotes,
things in that nature.
I'm not convinced that
this is the right strategy.
I'm really not.
What I am convinced about
is I wanna go Monday,
actually this now meeting within meeting,
I wanna go Monday through
Friday with DailyVee.
- Yup.
- And then Saturday Sunday
do the stuff that actually
drives to Gary Vaynerchuk.
Maybe we can call it
Gary Vaynerchuk Weekend
and drive towards this
'cause it's that content.
- What do you mean, driving?
- So we'll talk about this,
sorry, just let me finish off this,
but like I don't wanna crowd the channel
with two posts per day like we were doing,
so I wonder is Saturday and
Sunday we do Gary Vaynerchuk
YouTube channel stuff
and siphon the DailyVee
million, 850,000, to Gary
Vaynerchuk which is right now
51,000, right?
- Right now, we just have so much that
we can post every day on this.
- And I want to.
- And, so for the weekends,
- I want to.
- We're just prioritizing key notes.
- On GaryVee.
- GaryVee right now is
only Monday through Friday.
- Monday through Friday, got
it, fine, I'm good with that.
We should probably do a
little, so then we gotta start,
either we use this clip, or
we need to create an original
PS. There's a Gary Vaynerchuk
channel kind of thing.
- [Man] Maybe we can edit in--
- Actually I got an idea.
Hey guys, thank you so much for watching.
- They wanna do a follow up to it,
where you do a call to
action to your audience
that filled out the survey.
- Okay.
- I've looked at it, and
the questions were like
kinda meh, but I figured if
we, and they're not talking
about we're gonna distribute the results.
So right now you're just gonna do a video
and they would share that video, like hey,
fill out this survey.
But I was like, oh, if we
come up with a good survey
that we think is gonna have strong results
that you can then like make
up post-mortem thing off of
that they'll post on their channel.
- I wasn't listening.
- [Juanpa] Gary, what's up?
- What up brother, how are you?
- [Juanpa] Very great, you?
- Very good man, what's up?
- [Juanpa] So the big news is that
because of the huge
noise that made (muffled)
right now we are still working
on getting to that goal,
and I'm about to post a
video with every Mexican
that participated giving
an update to the audience.
- Real quick, my friend
Juan who I've been really
impressed with watching him
grow as a young entrepreneur
and hustler hit me up,
he's doing a GoFundMe
for obviously the very
difficult time in Mexico City
that are brewing post all the earthquakes
and I'm just really
excited to support him,
I'm about to post
something to him right now,
obviously bringing awareness to causes
and things that nature is,
most of you know most of the stuff I do
is always behind the scenes,
there's a lot of noise around
events and so I'm always
trying to be strategic around
delivering steak when it
matters, more so than sizzle,
like a tweet here a thing there,
everybody feels good about
themselves as an advocate.
I tend to like to just do
it quietly, that's my norm.
But sometimes you just go random
and you do stuff in a different way
and so I'm really excited
about posting this video
on Instagram right now
and putting it in the vlog
and bringing awareness to his GoFundMe
that has already generated
a quarter million dollars
to help out individuals in
Mexico City build their homes
back up and so that's what
I'm up to right now before the
wine event.
That's amazing brother,
I'm literally about to film
my piece of content right now.
- [Juanpa] Awesome, awesome.
If you were to use the fact
that we're gonna rebuild houses
and it's really, really strong, you can.
- Okay, I'm literally taking screen shots
of this Facetime, I may use
this content as the main thing
because it might be the most
authentic version of it y'know?
- [Juanpa] Okay, copy that.
So should I be smiling,
should I be serious?
- The best part is I
already took what I needed
while you didn't know it was coming
so that it was really good.
- [Juanpa] Okay.
- Alright, so listen man,
I'm super impressed by you in general
and then for you to be
giving back to your country
this way inspires the shit out of me,
so I'm exactly pumped to support
and so I'm honored right now
and I'll talk to you soon.
- [Juanpa] Awesome, I
really appreciate this Gary,
I want to talk to you before
for other types of things.
You inspire a lot, I like how you think,
so after this let's
definitely get in touch.
- 100% I'll talk to you soon my man.
- [Jaunpa] Thank you brother.
- Bye.
(chill music)
- So something that has
been really beneficial to me
is Stephen Ross, not
because I actually use him--
- [Woman] Who's Stephen Ross?
- Stephen Ross is my business partner,
he owns the Miami
Dolphins, he owns a piece
of BNRX.
- [Woman] The Business School of Michigan.
- Business School of Michigan.
He's 76 years old, 77 years old,
and he acts like me, and he
acts like kids younger than me.
He's 77 an on straight fucking fire.
And it's been great
because when I got to him
I'd come out of a decade of Silicon Valley
19 year olds, right?
And I'm in such a great
place, I'm 41 years old,
I'll be 42 in November,
and I think for real,
that a lot of probably why
I think I can buy the Jets
and other things is
and I talk before a lot about
this, we're very friendly,
and I'm always like, we're just starting,
this is like where do you think we are?
I think, I genuinely think
a 55 year old executive,
a 55 year executive, is
fairly, I don't know,
getting close to maybe half-time.
Hey guys, thank you so
much for watching DailyVee,
I really appreciate it, as you can tell
we've taken a new YouTube channel strategy
and we created a second
channel /GaryVaynerchuk.
Please subscribe, that is
where business meetings
and keynotes are gonna reside.
Not sure if this is the right strategy
of having two channels, but fuck it,
I'm gonna try some shit.
Go subscribe, check it.
(chill music)
You been in it?
- Yeah.
- Phil's been in every
fucking room in New York City.